markets have always done this and I
think that that is the thing my big
areas of study obviously are in the on
the quantitative side of things I I've
spent 30 years studying that side of the
market but I've also spent a lot of time
understanding evolutionary biology and
psychology because if you get a really
good understanding of men and women and
the way we are emotionally designed you
can you can have much greater faith in
saying nope it's gonna happen exactly
the same way it happened before mm-hmm
and and you know it's funny because
something that didn't cause anyone any
consternation six months ago
now becomes that is that's gonna kill us
so you know the US government is gonna
make crypto illegal okay and they're
gonna give the death penalty if you are
found having crypto pretty strong
deterrent mm-hmm you know FDR did it
with gold he confiscated all gold in the
1930s because he was going moving
completely off the gold standard because
he had to and everyone complied and so
having the world's biggest economy be
unable to participate in crypto would
definitely put a crimp in its style
conversely if you look at black markets
right and that is something that I've
looked at over the years black markets
are enormous even in free market
societies like our own mm-hmm think
about housekeepers think about drugs
think about people who sell cigarettes
that don't pay the tax
yeah so even in a relatively free market
like the US huge black market and then
take places like Venezuela or whatever
and it's all black market the
interesting thing about those black
markets is they are all priced in u.s.
dollars
so there is an inertia a huge amount of
money that's at stake and sure could
some of those people cook convert their
their dollars to cryptocurrency actually
there's a lot of good reasons why they
should right but you know a lot of again
inertia is another one of the laws that
I just love and thank you
Sir Isaac Newton you know people are
really strange in that oh I've got time
I've got time I've got time and then
their time runs out
so I think that you know I as I say I
don't know enough to to be a bull or a
bear on the whole space you we were
talking earlier and and I think that one
of your strategies I know you have many
but one of your strategies about who
during the gold rush you know building
the hotels Eldin the pickaxes selling
the pails that works mm-hmm that works
really well and so I think that there's
all sorts of secondary and ancillary
people who can make a lot of money from
crypto but I definitely think that the
the the crypto world is still mysterious
enough even to somebody like me who
knows just enough to be dangerous I know
guys I'm 58 so I know guys my own age
don't have a clue yep and they'll call
me on the phone and they'll say Jim you
know you you understand this crypto
thing I have no here's Patrick's number
call him because and and frankly we
O'Shaughnessy family partners which is
our family office did make a small
investment in crypto just to see how it
worked
because we thought well this has the
potential to be big so we want to see
I'm a huge believer in you can't learn
anything unless you've got to get in the
game yep you know because what happens
is you intellectualize everything and
you oh I would have definitely sold
there
you wouldn't you wouldn't have sold
there everyone's a genius and I'd say
exactly exactly everyone's from Lake
woebegone right above average so I I
believe that you know we're doing a lot
of really interesting work right now on
machine learning and again to really
really understand you've got to have
you've got to have your own money on the
line